[音楽]
皆さんこんにちは
こんにちはーこんな
みかです
私は大学で中国語と日本語と
書道を教えていますそれから
民間の英会話教室で
英語を教えていた時期がありますところで
突然ですが
これは
誰でしょうこちら30年前30年前の私
ですこの時
結婚話に
舞い上がっていました
大学3年生の時です
大学3年生の時
当時高校1年から付き合っていたボーイ
フレンドに
就職活動をしないで
大学卒業したら
結婚して一緒に地方に赴任しようと言われ
まして私もすっかりその気になりましたで
それで
就職活動をしなかったんですでところが
大学4年
就職活動期間も終わりました
公務員試験も終わりましたその頃
突然
婚約破棄を言い渡されたんでした
理由は私が大学にいたからです
4大卒の女性は向かいたくないと
向こうのご両親が
断固として譲らなかったんですねでそれで
亡くなりました私は目の前がもう
真っ暗になりました
大学卒業後どうしたらいいんだでこういう
切実な問題が
突然目の前に立ちはだかったんですでその
時に見たものそれが
ポスターです
ポスターにはこう書いてました
中国黒竜交渉ハルピン市販大学
交換留学生
募集
これにしようともうフラフラになりながら
あこれにしようと決めました
当時の中国は今と違って随分物価が安かっ
たんですねでそれから経費も
交換留学生ですからそれほどかからないと
いうのが決めていになりましたここねハル
フィンですハルピンの街で
京劇の格好させていただきました
私はその留学先のハルピンの街で中国人
以外に
ソ連人あと韓国人
北朝鮮人
アメリカ人と交流を持ちましたそこで
平和な日本に行っては知り得なかったこと
を知ったんです
私が留学したのは1991年です
1991年当時
ソ連という国がありましたところがその
ソ連という国はその年の12月に崩壊し
ます
法開して
ロシアとそれ以外の国になりました
突然ロシア人になった私の友人
泣きながら帰国をしました
それから
他にも忘れられないこととしては
北朝鮮から来ていた留学生ハルピーの町は
真冬ではマイナス40度にもなりますその
マイナス40度のハルピーの街を逃亡し
ました
すぐに北朝鮮から
秘密警察の人が来ました
彼の行方を追いました
それから皆さんは
誰かに監視されたという思いはありますか
当時
社会主義国は
KGBに
代表される組織に一般の人々も
鑑賞されていましたこれらの
事実をして私はすごい衝撃を受けました
自分はもっと勉強しなければいけないと
思いました
学問を積んで
自分の幸福だけではなく
社会的に利益になることをしなければなら
ないと思いました
一生懸命勉強する私を日本人以外の人々は
褒めてくれましたあなたは学歴が高い
あなたは頭がいい
優しい
素晴らしい女性ですよと私はびっくりし
ました
日本では高額歴の女性は人気がありません
というと今度は彼らがびっくりしました
当時の日本は今よりも
女性の高額歴というのは
結婚や就職の障害であるとみられていまし
た
日本では
頭のいい女と結婚したくないという男性が
多いんですと言うとどうしてどうして頭の
悪い女がいいのという言葉が返ってきまし
た
そもそもの女性の社会的地位が違うのだな
と思ったのですではここで
皆さん
世界
男女平等ランキングを見てみましょう
これは
世界経済フォーラムが
ジェンダーギャップ指数に基づいて出した
ものです
ジェンダーギャップ指数というのは4つの
分野から構成されます
前代ギャップ指数は1つ目
政治2つ目経済
教育あと健康この4つの分野から総合的に
判断されたのがジェンダーギャップ指数
です1アイスランドにノルウェー3位
スウェーデン4位フィンランド
北欧の国々が並びます
濃いニカラグは
6位で
7位ニュージーランド
8フィリピンです
意外に思える国はないですか
私はありますよ
1位から4位までの
北欧の国々の特徴は
育児のしやすさです
北欧の国々の取り組みはよくマスコミで
報道されてますから
皆さんもご存知なのではないでしょうか
では
次の
ニカラグアいきます
ニカラグは
ニカラグアは南アメリカの国ですね
2006年までは
62でしたそれが
政治と社会の取り組みで5位まで断固上げ
てきたんですそして
女性の地位というのは
物理的な人口比によっても採用されます
それが
ルワンダです
ルワンダ
1994年
民族対立によって大虐殺が起きました
そのことで労働人口が
激減します
つまり
女性も働かないでいてはみんなが働か
なければ社会が成り立たなくなったのです
そのことが
女性の地を押し上げました
ただしルワンダは都市と
地方では全然状況が違います
地方の女性の地位は低いですそのために
社会問題が起きますから
JICAが
ドワンダの地方に行って
農業プロジェクトを行っていますそして
次が
7位のニュージーランドこの写真見たこと
ある人いるんじゃないでしょうか
いますねはい
皆さんここはニュージーランドのどこ
でしょうそしてこの
男性
誰でしょう
こちらの
男性
ニュージーランドの国会の議長です
そしてここは国会です
国会の最中です
国会の最中年議長の男性が赤ちゃんに
伸びるくあげてるんですねでこの
状況に感動した人たくさんいましたです
からこの写真が世界中に発信されたんです
そして
8フィリピンです
A
フィリピンのイメージなんでしょう私の
フィリピンのイメージはバナナです
青い海ですそれからサービス業で働く女性
たちです
ところがフィリピン国内に目を向けてい
ましょう
フィリピン国内では
富裕層ではなくても
ヘルパーさんが家事や育児を手伝ってくれ
ますまあそれが仕事としていますそれを
普通に雇っていますそのことが
会社やオフィスで働くホワイトカラーの
女性を助けているんですねそして日本に
戻ります日本は110
位です
149カ国110位ですそれでも
去年の114円からはランクアップしてた
んですよ日本では
ヘルパーさんに家事や育児を頼むと
愛情が足りないんじゃないのと言われる
ことがあります
また2017年
熊本市議会で市議の女性が赤ちゃんを連れ
て出席しようとしましたしかしそれは
認められませんでした
では皆さん
次にですね
こちら高等教育の在学率を
国際比較見てみましょう
青いラインが男性です
赤いラインが女性ですこの
グラフにあります
オーストリアアメリカ
フィンランド
女性の方が高等教育在学率が高いんですね
でそのことは
フランスやロシアなんかにも言われます
ですから
世界的に見ると
女性の高等教育在学率が
男性よりも高いというのは珍しくないん
ですね日本
男性65.7%
女性は5%ほど低い60.9%そしてこの
中にはですね女性の中には
短大に進学する女性も含まれています
では日本は日本の女性は高等教育への進学
を阻まれているんでしょうかと思いますか
最新のデータを見てみたいと思いますこの
グラフも含めてこれから見せるグラフは
すべて
内閣府と
文科省のデータから作っています
はい
男女別
進学水大学の進学推移です私が大学生だっ
た平成元年の頃
女性の大学進学率は
わずか15%
ほどです
男性は30%ちょっとですねそれが
令和元年今年
女性の大学進学率は
50.7%まで上がりました
男性は56.6%ですから
本当に
差が縮まったんですね
女性の進学率何倍にも増えました
では
女性の地位が向上すれば何かいいことが
あるんでしょうか
よく問題されるけれどどんないいことが
はいではその答えを出してくれたのが
IMFの論文です
IMF
世界通貨基金が2012年
女性は日本を救えるかという論文を発表し
ましたどういう内容か
簡単に言いましょう
日本は
先進国の中で
極端に専業主婦率が高い
そして日本は
先進国の中で極端に女性の管理職率が低い
ということは
まだパワーがあるんじゃないね使ってない
パワーがあるでしょ
女性の力を使えば
労働力不足は解消されるんじゃないですか
経済は豊かになるんでじゃないですか
社会はもっと良くない分ではないですかと
いうものですそして
同じ年の2012年
IMFは日本に提言を行いましたもっと
専業主婦の比率を
減らした方がいいんじゃないですかという
提言です
女性の血が上がったことによって出生率が
低下したんだという人がいます
実際はどうなんでしょう見てみましょう
はいこちら
縦軸が出生率です
横軸女性の労働率です
1970年代どの国も出生率を大幅に
減らしています
しかしその後ですね日本以外は
右上がりになってきている
右上がりというのはつまりですね
土星女性の労働率の上昇とともに出生率が
上がったということです
日本には
待機児童の問題があります
しかし
待機児童の問題があるということは
子供がいて
働こうという意思のある女性が増えたと
いうことです
そしてその問題は
徐々に
解消されつつあります
皆さんここで
チャーチルの言葉を紹介しましょう
基幹主義者は
すべての工期の中に困難を見つけるが
楽観主義者は
すべての困難の中に
好機を見出す
今の状況を
悲観的ではなく
楽観的に見れば
ジェンダーギャップによる不平等があると
いうことはまだまだ改善の余地があると
いうことです
日本は
世界男女平等ランキング110位です
しかしそれと同時に
世界第3位の
経済大国でありますこの日本でですね
女性が
社会が
意識改革をして
女性がもっと活用されるようになればどう
なると思いますか
もっと経済的に
活躍すればどうなると思いますか
豊かになれば
経済的に豊かになれば心に余裕が生まれ
ます
心に余裕が生まれれば
優しい雰囲気で包まれるでしょうそうすれ
ば出生率も
上昇していくとは思いませんか
今回は
狭間という全体の大きなテーマの中から
ジェンダーギャップ
男性と
女性の狭間を取り上げましたこの
狭間
縮まったらどうなるでしょう私はもっと
より良い社会が生まれるのではないかと
思います
私の話は以上です
[拍手]
[音楽]